this is a fox news alert and we don't
say that lightly
day two of the democratic national
convention begins tonight featuring bill
clinton
and alexandria ocasio-cortez sandy we'll
be monitoring it
we've taken a look at the democrats
platform and found something interesting
they don't think it's safe for african
americans to go outside
as the platform says quote it's
unacceptable that millions of people in
our country have good reason to fear
they may lose their lives in a routine
traffic stop or standing on a street
corner while playing with a toy in a
public park
it's scary is it true michelle obama
echoed this sentiment recently in fact
last night
but again is it rooted in reality jason
whitlock has been watching carefully
he writes for and is part owner of
outkick.com which is excellent we're
happy to have him on
tonight jason whitlock thanks so much
for coming on what do you make of this
you hear a lot
i think that fear is a mechanism a tool
for control
and the democratic party the mainstream
media
are using fear to control people
and to control african americans in
particular you cannot
function properly if you live in
an irrational fear again for those of us
that have
religious faith we understand that
fear is the is the friend of evil
and the reason you embrace faith is so
that you can operate without fear and
you can reach your highest potential
this is just an irrational fear again
when they put that into the platform
when michelle obama
echoes those thoughts i'm just like what
black communities
have they actually lived in because that
is not the fear that is pervasive
through our black communities
fear being stopped by the police and
killed the stats
the facts the evidence don't back up
this irrational fear
so why is someone trying to instill
that fear in us of the police it's like
a self-fulfilling prophecy
if you engage with the police filled
with fear
you're more likely to make really bad
decisions
that then provoke them to take action
it's irresponsible what they're doing
and what they're saying
i never thought of that part of it but
you're absolutely right and you're
absolutely right that fear makes every
single human
being irrational me you everybody
so i wonder what the long-term
consequences
of this are apart from the one you just
mentioned like what what kind of scar
does this leave on the country if you
keep saying stuff like this
look the number one thing you can do to
prevent someone from reaching their
potential
is convince them that they can't and to
convince them that the whole country is
rigged against them
therefore why even try give someone an
excuse
not to be successful give someone an
excuse to behave
improperly when dealing with the police
is how you ensure
failure i was brought up my entire life
to go out and attack the world and
anything was a possibility
that was the hope that was put in me
coming i was born in 1967
my parents lived through the civil
rights movement our their goal their
hope for me and my brother my
step-sister and step brother
was for us to go out and conquer the
world
we're now telling kids you can't conquer
the world
and so if you're a black kid competing
against
asian kids white kids latino kids and
you've been convinced
oh the whole system's rigged against you
you can't succeed
and the other kid you're competing with
are out there
the world's on a platter for me if i
just go out and attack it and work hard
i'm going to be successful
you have less of a chance of competing
against your peers
if your attitude and mindset aren't
right
attitude controls outcome
and i why the democrats
this is just i'm just sorry it's pure
evil it's
it's borderline satanic if you really
have an
understanding of religious faith the
principles taught in the bible
why jesus died on a cross for us if
god's on your side how can you fail
i just it's sickening to me what this
message and to see a major political
party
pump this message into the black
community
is really disheartening for me
you're making me emotional uh listening
that because i think you're so i think
you're so right
jason whitlock thank you very much for
that thank you